le jingle c'est bien anna ne bouge pas
pour le jingle vous non plus adriana
c'est bien les filles bien alors
attention c'est compliqué c'est
l'interview nude c'est la main que vous
préférez votre père votre mère c'est nul
j'avais averti c'est nul
ouais mais je vous réponds les deux
manger ça dépend de la nuit ma mère qui
est morte et le jour mon père qui est en
vie vous préférez hitler ou staline
staline quand même pourquoi parce qu'il
a tué plus de gens non non pour une eau
non pour une nouvelle aide à la
différence si vous voulez c'est que le
communisme est un rêve dramatiquement
avorter le nazisme n'a jamais eu une
part de rêve commise le communisme vous
l'avez dit vous-même c'est un idéal des
voiliers ouais le nazisme les panières
le mot le mot le plus con en amour c'est
merci encore oui oui je trouve que lewis
est plus ambivalent
alors vous préféreriez mourir comme john
lennon qui a été abattu par un coup de
revolver comme otis redding qui est mort
dans une chute dans un accident d'avion
un crash comme janis joplin qui est
morte d'une overdose ou comme bones code
le chanteur décide ici qu'est s'est
étouffé dans son vomi assas plus
originales comme les bonnes scott normal
la prochaine fois on verra mamac avec
des petites cornes comme et si d'ici et
puis un short comme ambition si vous
préféreriez mourir tout de suite et
aller au paradis ou vivre encore
printemps est là en enfer en vivent
encore 30 ans et aller en enfer
comme je crois nir paradinha la gagne et
les transports vous vous laver les
cheveux tous les combien comme vous plus
trois fois par semaine est ce que vous
préférez un président d'extrême droite
élu au suffrage universel ou pas
d'élection du tout pas d'élection du
tout ah oui vous arrêtez développer le
président d'extrême droite élu sera
gilles mercier ne supprimera l'élection
au coup d'après ouais donc à tout
prendre c'est ce qui s'est passé avec
hitler c'est un ce qui s'est passé voilà
qui est clair
alors acquis confieriez-vous plus
facilement vos enfants si vous
disparaissez y ait un maxime gremetz
noël mamère ou jean louis debré au avec
maxime dereymez je suis sûr qu'ils
iraient à l'école et qu'ils auraient de
bonnes notes
j'aimerais vous retourner vers le
communisme lui quand même alors imagine
est une vue de l'esprit
vous rentrez chez vous vous trouvez
votre femme au lit avec rocco siffredi
c'est un jeu l'esprit vous restez en
participant vous restez en boudant où
vous restez en vous pendant je médite
vous éviterez minutes vous partez pas à
jamais aucune situation voyait même à
votre question je pars pas jeudi à dakar